c'était épouvantable
c'est frappant de voir comment les flics
n'ont pas retenu la leçon au cours de
ces deux derniers mois celle des gens
dans ce pays qui protestent contre la
brutalité et les graves violences
policières et qu'un flic sorte dégaine
son arme vers un afro américain qui a le
dos tourné et marche vers sa voiture
c'est juste fou c'est juste fou c'est
immoral
[Musique]
une autre vie a été perdu à cause de la
brutalité policière et malheureusement
avec les réseaux sociaux nous apprenons
que ce n'est pas une anomalie quand tu l
cela arrive tout le temps mais si nous
sommes organisés que nous faisons partie
d'une communauté qui se soucie les uns
des autres nous pouvons faire la
différence
écoutez à présent l'analyse de drieu
godefridi hauteur de la révolution trump
aux éditions texte qui peut attendre que
les différents partis jeudi heure qui
sont intervenus danse dans cette
opération de police et eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer avant de se livrer à des
commentaires moi je me garderai bien de
faire le moindre commentaire avant que
l'effet de soi avait re c'est pas parce
qu'une personne est décédée deux que
nécessairement la police a mal agi et
inversement ce n'est pas parce que c'est
la police qui intervient que
nécessairement l'action doit être
approuvé ce qui est certain en revanche
c'est que nous sommes dans une situation
où les milices du parti démocrate
on peut le dire puisque le financement
est en grande partie commun les milices
du parti démocrate n'attendent que ce
type d'incident d'événements à quelles
que soient les responsabilités
impliquées pour se livrer à des actes
qui relèvent effectivement des émeutes
insurrection